[Music]
what's up Wolfgang today we're gonna be
talking about a topic that has been
getting a lot of attention online
recently and many of you have asked me
to do a video particularly on this topic
so here it is but this video will
contain some infinity war spoilers so if
you haven't seen it first of all go see
it why haven't you and second of all
you've been warned and of course don't
forget about our giveaway we're giving
away a full speaker system and all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel subscribe to the stupendous wave
leave a like and drop a comment below
with your favorite superhero that could
be Marvel DC or otherwise so the topic
going around the web right now and what
people have been asking me is about
spider-man's death it was probably the
saddest part of Avengers infinity war
for most people especially when he falls
into Tony Stark's arms and they're
holding each other and he says I don't
want to go this is obviously very
heartbreaking for everybody because
everybody loves spider-man and everybody
loves Tom Holland but it seems that
spider-man dying at the end and
disintegrating was more dramatic than
all of the other Avengers dying
it took spider-man a considerably longer
time to disintegrate than it did all of
the other heroes this is actually
something I noticed the first time when
I watched it I didn't think too much
about it I just said to my buddy it's
taking spider-man a lot longer to
disintegrate than it did everybody else
but after seeing it for a second time
and a third time I came to the same
conclusion that the internet basically
came to and that is that spider-man
wasn't actually dying when the scene
started when he's talking to Tony Stark
he says I don't feel so good and his
body is still perfectly intact he hasn't
begun to disintegrate yet he starts
walking over to Tony and Tony tells them
that he's alright and then he says I
don't know what's happening but what
actually is happening here is that he
actually really does know what's
happening or his spidey senses at least
know what's happening his spidey senses
are triggered way before he starts to
disintegrate and although he may deny it
up first he ultimately does know what is
happening everybody else that started to
disintegrate didn't really know what was
going on they were confused a whole
entire time but when Spiderman started
to feel what was going on that's when he
started to tell Tony I don't want to go
I don't want to go not only does Peter
realize that he's about to die but he
realizes that a lot of other people are
dying as well some pretty good spidey
senses he's got there but this is why
his death takes so much longer than
everybody else and this is why the scene
is so dramatic plus he's a teenager and
beloved by everybody so unfortunately
although his spidey senses are great
they could not save him from the power
of the Infinity Gauntlet and so the
question I've been asked in the question
that's really being asked about all of
them who died is are they going to come
back are they gonna appear in Avengers 4
and nobody really knows this who's not
involved with a movie but my personal
opinion is of course they're gonna come
back Avengers 4 is widely and heavily
believed to be a time travel movie
whether they accomplish that by getting
the Infinity Gauntlet back from Thanos
whether it's pimp technology or start
technology or combination of all of them
it's heavily believed that somehow they
will go back in time and they will fix
it all to where the heroes come back and
let's think about who died right let's
think about all the major characters
that died of course they're gonna come
back because there's more movies to do
right you think Black Panther is not
going to come back after it just
destroyed some records there I mean the
Finity war came and destroyed it after
that but it hit major milestones you
don't think they're gonna do another
black panther dr. strange they're
definitely gonna do another Doctor
Strange movie the guardians of the
galaxy died really with the exception of
rocket and there's definitely gonna be a
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 there
better be because I want outta more lock
to come into the MCU and spider-man of
course they're gonna make another
spider-man everyone loves Tom Holland as
spider-man there's only been well I mean
really is only been one spider-man movie
that's been his yes he was in civil war
and infinity war but they're gonna make
another spider-man movie and I know that
even after the movie the Russo brothers
have come out and said that you better
accept the fact that the heroes that
died are dead and not coming back but
they're gonna make these other movies
and who knows what we could believe I
mean a lot has been misdirection before
infinity war like there were trailers
where the Hulk is running in will come
and we all know that the Hulk did not
come out again so in my opinion no the
characters who are dead are not
permanently dead they will be revived
somehow in Avengers 4 and if I'm wrong
then Marvel just killed all of their
upcoming characters and MCU but again
this is just all my personal opinion I
want to know what you guys think let me
know in the comments below
whether you think that these guys are
permanently dead or whether or not you
think they're coming back
also let me know your thoughts on
spider-man spidey senses and whether or
not you sobbed like a baby during the
movie thanks for watching this video if
you enjoyed it please give it a like and
subscribe to my channel to join the wolf
gang also don't forget about our speaker
giveaway all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave leave a like and drop a
comment below with your favorite
superhero and you'll be entered thank
you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf so cool couldn't find the
owner so I just left a note just lost
old American lady she was really nice
and got me and Shiro I'm just um feel
like I could be doing more
you know I'm just curious when our next
real missions gonna be she had just
called me back it's Peter